[Music]  I think crystal is trying to look like  she's staying confident but you can just  tell that she's getting a little bit  more insecure she's starting to see that  maybe she isn't the only girl he's  interested in I think she's kind of  starting to panic  you ready I'm ready all right good luck  thank you yeah I appreciate it  let me just start off by saying this  week's been really good because I know  love is here with that let's begin  [Music]  wait I'm sorry would you mind if I just  had a quick moment of your time  yeah what could she possibly be talking  to him about she doesn't really care  about what anyone else thinks or feels  so I'm hoping Ari is starting to catch  on to that as well  crystals pulling a quick move right now  and I don't know that it's in her favor  after this week to be doing that